- I talk about the Larry
Elder interview in that
and where, after he beat me senseless,
my editors and my
director and my producers
wanted to cut it.
They didn't want it to air and I said,
"Guys, if I'm anything
that I purport to be
"as an interviewer, we have to put it up."
And I saw it get clipped
a million times on YouTube
and "Larry Elder Destroys" in
capital letters, "Libtard",
and you know, and blah blah blah.
But what I realized
almost within a day was,
holy cow, people were
having their wake-up moment
right alongside of me.
(rhythmic synth music)
- Hey, everyone, it's Andrew Klavan.
We're here with the Don't
Burn This Book book club,
we're doing chapter five,
Check Your Facts, Not Your Privilege.
Which is a chapter after my own heart,
I'm very big on facts.
It reminded me of what
Ronald Reagan once said.
He said, "It's not that
Democrats don't know anything,
"it's that everything they
know happens to be untrue."
And I think that this
is something that comes
to all of us when we are,
as they say, red pilled.
When we start to realize
that all the things
we took for granted,
all the positions we took for granted,
really aren't based in any kind of facts.
They're based in a kind
of emotional brow beating
that the Left uses instead of ideas.
And this is one of the
things about the Left,
they don't have a lot of ideas
but they have a lot of techniques
for silencing people with ideas
and for frightening people with ideas.
And I have to say, one of
the things I liked about,
this chapter's packed with facts,
it's packed with information,
stuff you can use
to beat up your
grandmother at Thanksgiving
if she has a bad opinion.
(Dave laughing)
But I think the most
important part of this chapter
is the discussion about the fact that
when we talk to each other,
when Liberals and Conservatives
talk to one another,
they are talking in different languages.
I would go even further
in saying they're talking
from a completely different point of view.
So, Dave, I'd like to
talk to you about that
'cause that was the thing
that really grabbed me
was this idea that we're
not communicating at all.
We think we're arguing with one another
but we're actually not putting
across our ideas at all.
Is that a fair way to say it?
- It is a fair way and Klaven,
before I say anything else,
one of the reasons that I wanted
you to handle this chapter
is because I think you
are one of the better
communicators we have
on these type of ideas
because often it is that lens
that is the screwed up part.
It's hard to tell how people
think about the world,
where their biases are
and everything else.
And I find you to be
a very clear communicator on this stuff.
And of course you do work
with that fast-talking
orthodox Jew who's always talking,
what's that thing about
facts and feelings?
Right?
There's something that he's
always saying about that.
- Yeah.
- So I thought there was--
- Absolutely.
- You're around him a lot
so I thought it would work.
So, yeah, we can dive into
some of the nitty-gritty
of the specifics but I agree
that the part about the lenses
really is the most interesting part here.
You know, some of us view the
world, so, me, for example,
I really view the world through
mostly what is thought of,
in an American, sense
as a Libertarian lens.
That I want you as the
individual to basically
be able to do whatever you want
but not purely whatever you want.
You can't infringe on
your neighbor's rights,
you can't steal from people,
you can't murder people,
things like that and this
is where I always say,
people always say, "Well,
Dave, what's the difference
"between a Classical
Liberal and a Libertarian?"
And I always say, "Well,
I want a little bit more
"of the basic guidelines around society
"than I think a pure Libertarian does."
And then we have people that view things
through more of a Conservative lens
that generally is more that
they're trying to defend
the family and sort of long-fought
battles that they view
built Western civilization
that has sort of fought against barbarism
as they would call it.
And I actually have
become very sympathetic
to that view as well.
And then there's sort
of the more progressive,
or, I think it's really
called Liberal lens,
although I always am trying
to clean up the difference
between sort of Progressive and Liberal.
Which is more sort of about
the oppressed and the oppressor
and I think that's the most
muddled lens these days
because if you live in the West,
and especially if you
live in the United States,
you are not oppressed, you have actually
the greatest privilege there is.
Which is that you live in a free society.
That isn't to say it is perfect.
We know it is not perfect.
But I don't believe a
perfect society can exist.
I think once you try to
create a perfect society,
you're gonna have to take
out a lot of people to do it
because people are imperfect.
So I think that general
idea of sort of figuring out
how you look at the world,
what sort of pecking order
you put the importance of these things in,
is a really important thing
and then, to your point,
then when you find oh,
well, here's someone
who looks at the world
so differently than me,
they don't accept facts as I accept facts.
Or they have what they view to be
a completely different set of facts.
Well, then you can start
unpacking that a little bit
because you can have an appreciation,
oh, it's just that their
hierarchy is a little different
than my hierarchy and
we have to figure out
how to be able to do some talking here.
- You know, like you, I
came over from the Left,
and I shifted over to the
Right almost not knowing it
'cause I was out of the
country when it happened.
I was living in England and I came back
and found I had shifted to the right.
And I had this innocent
sense that oh, wow, you know,
if only my fellow friends on the Left knew
what I now knew, they would
see that they have made
this terrible mistake and
I went around explaining
to my former friends who
now no longer talk to me.
And when I follow you on
Twitter, I see you often
saying to people, "What you
just said is not based in fact"
or "Now you're starting to see the facts.
"Why don't you come on my
show and we'll talk about it."
How often do people respond to that?
How often do you get
people who are willing
to engage with you in this journey?
- Well, unfortunately,
it's becoming less and less
because so many of the people on the Left,
I think, have turned
from, say, honest debate
to just personal attacks.
And I am always willing to open my door,
or in this case my Skype,
to anyone that wants to
talk to me respectfully.
But if you're endlessly going to attack me
or attack my motives or
lie about me, you know,
there's a certain set of people
that will just lie about you
relentlessly and then say,
"See, and you won't
bring me on your show."
And it's like, well,
that's not really the game
that I'm interested in
playing but it is fascinating
to me what you're talking
about there which is
that you thought, 'cause I
think a lot of ex-Lefties,
which, by the way, I think
is truly the biggest-growing
and unspoken political
group in the United States.
It's the decent Liberals who
are waking up against Leftism.
But I think a lot of
them are sort of thinking
what you just laid out there which is,
"Oh, I've woken up to some stuff,
"it clearly is more fact
based and more freeing
"as a human being and
suddenly I'm realizing,
"oh, these Conservatives that
I thought were the bad guys,
"or whatever, they're not so bad."
But they're afraid to say it
and not only afraid to say it,
they're shocked that people
don't start coming with them.
But there's a reason for that
and the reason, of course,
is that once you've called everybody
else bigots and racists,
you know that will be turned against you.
But one of the things to
just further your point,
you know, it's interesting
'cause I know you and I have
still some pretty significant
political disagreements.
You are pro-life, I make a
pro-choice argument in this book.
I think you're for the
death penalty, right?
- I'm not for the death
penalty as it stands
but I'm potentially for the death penalty.
- Okay, so, I'm against the death penalty,
I've heard some great
arguments, Dennis Prager makes,
I think, a fantastic argument
for the death penalty.
I just don't like the idea
of giving the state that much power.
I'm still for some level
of public education,
I'm for dignity with
death, you should be able
to make choices at the end.
I'm for legalizing marijuana, I mean,
we could go into a bunch of things
that you and I don't
really see eye to eye on.
But I think the purpose of this chapter
was also to show people,
people on the right,
they're willing to sit there and do it.
Sit there and debate it and go through
all the grit and the dirt
that you have to get to
to be able to form a functioning society.
And unfortunately, that
doesn't really exist
on the other side.
- You know, you start this
chapter, this is chapter five,
Check Your Facts, Not Your Privilege,
you start it with you having
a debate with Larry Elder
and I did feel sorry for
you 'cause that's like
shooting a nail gun into
your foot, you know?
I mean, the guy has a real
mastery of facts and information.
But it was about racism
and black people in America
and we're having this
conversation on the day
when the Pulitzer Prize is being given
to The New York Times for
a completely dishonest take
on slavery and black
people, their 1619 Project.
So much of the division between
us is keyed around race.
A lot of it is keyed around
gender but so much of it starts
with this idea that
somehow we are perpetually
in a racist state of systemic
racism in this country.
And Larry Elder, in your
chapter, he basically takes you
to task and he says,
"Show me, show me where that racism is."
The question I get asked
more often than any other is,
"How can I convince people
that we are not in this state?
that we can actually become
"one country despite
the color differences?"
Is that something that
you feel is possible
or are these two different languages
just so completely separate that we can't
reach across that barrier?
- You know, it's such a great question
and I would say this, I don't
think I could do what I do
and I suspect you couldn't do what you do
if you didn't think it was
possible to bridge this divide.
It would be like,
what would we really be
doing with our lives?
Why would we be talking about these things
if we didn't think that the good ideas
could ultimately conquer the bad ones?
Or that the sunlight
would expose the bad ideas
or the rest of it?
So, you know, I talk about the
Larry Elder interview in that
and where, after he beat me senseless,
my editors and my
director and my producers
wanted to cut it.
They didn't want it to air and I said,
"Guys, if I'm anything
that I purport to be
"as an interviewer, we have to put it up."
And I saw it get clipped
a million times on YouTube
and "Larry Elder destroys,"
in capital letters, "libtard."
And you know blah, blah, blah.
But what I realized
almost within a day was
holy cow, people were
having their wake-up moment
right alongside of me.
So as I write, I don't know
how many people in our biz,
or in any business, can
say my best and worst
professional moment were
at the exact same time.
But that's truly what happened.
It was my worst moment
because I came to a gunfight
not ready, with no weapon
attached, because I just thought,
"Oh, I say things" and
that's what Lefties do,
that's it sort of, just because
you say it, it is right.
Systemic racism exists, it is right.
America is racist, it's
divinely right in and of itself.
So it was my worst moment because of that
but it was my best
because in the face of it,
once I got countered, I
don't know where it came from
exactly but I showed some humility
and I let it be a learning
experience for other people.
But to directly answer your question about
can we get through this,
I think there's a lot of
people that in many ways
don't want us to get through this.
There's a lot of people
that thrive on keeping
racial tensions stoked
and it's the anti-racists
who actually are pushing the
most racism into society,
the supposed anti-racists,
who are the ones that are
obsessed with our color of
our skin and our sexuality
and our gender and the rest of it.
And then it's the other
side that just doesn't care
about that stuff and then they use it as,
"Oh, you don't care what
color someone's skin is?
"You're the racist."
And it's like, no,
that's actually reverse,
we gotta work through this thing.
Can we get through it, I think, is like,
that's the billion-dollar question.
And I think the answer, if
we can wake up enough people,
and that's exactly why I wrote the book.
If we can wake up enough people
to exactly what individual rights are,
to why the Constitution is so great,
to why America, unlike any other country
in the history of the world,
that not only brought all of
these people here to blend in
but also to keep their
traditions and ethnicity
and all of those things.
But we also expand
rights over time, right?
We had slaves, we got rid of it.
Then black people could vote.
Women couldn't vote, now they can vote.
Gay people can get married.
We've expanded and expanded
and expanded rights
and I know that it will
be my Conservative friends
who, if in the future, there's
some other group of people
who don't have equality,
equality under the law,
it doesn't mean you have
to morally like them
or something like that.
I know that it will be
the liberty-minded people
that will defend people's ability
to be equal under the law.
While it's the Lefties
who will be sort of using
them as a crudgel to gain power.
And that really is the
important distinction.
You're not just anti-racist
because you say you're anti-racist.
You're anti-racist when you
get out of everyone's lives
so that they can live
whatever their best life is.
- You now find yourself in what
I think is the biggest tent,
which is the Conservative
side or the right-wing side,
whatever you wanna call it,
where there are in fact
people, as you said yourself,
there are people who
hold your points of view
but there are people who hold
very different points of view.
And yet, and yet, there is something
that is bringing us all together.
There is something that makes it easy
for Ben Shapiro and
Dave Rubin to be friends
even when they have complete
differences of opinions.
What is the moment, you know,
you talked about gay marriage
and more freedom for gay
people, I'm old enough,
I remember people being
literally arrested for being gay.
The police could go into a gay bar
and wait 'til somebody hit on 'em,
and arrest you for that so I
actually remember that time
and it's a huge, huge, change.
And I personally have been glad to see it
but for awhile on the Right,
I was talking to myself.
For a while I was saying, you
know, we're wrong about this,
we should shift over and
it has shifted somewhat.
But you're still in this tent with people
who strongly disagree with you.
What is it, do you
think, that unites them?
That unites you to people that you know
might have feelings about you which
are not as open as you'd like them to be?
- I think the literal
answer is individual rights,
that that is the bedrock
principle of the Right,
individual rights.
If you are a member of a society,
a legal member of society,
then you should be treated
equally under the law.
We are not gonna re-jigger
and re-organize things
so that everyone is exactly equal
and I've said this many
times but some people
are born into more money, some
people are born into less.
Some people are born drug addicted,
some people are genuinely luckier in life.
Some people make their luck.
Some people work hard, some people don't.
The Lefties are all
obsessed with those things.
Society can't fix those things,
that's actually impossible.
That's what the quest of life is about.
Society can just make it equal.
So I think that's the literal answer.
I think the figurative answer is sort of,
from an American perspective,
I think almost everyone
that identifies as a
Conservative or a Libertarian
or a Classical Liberal or
let's say a disaffected Lefty,
I think there's an
innate pride in America.
I am deeply, deeply proud,
it's not even proud.
Truly, I thank God that I am an American,
that I was born in this country
that is the freest place ever.
You've been to my house and my studio,
I have a giant American
flag sitting in there,
it's about five foot by eight foot.
We've got the Constitution
and the Bill of Rights
on the wall in there, too.
I'm not doing that for theater.
These are the greatest man-made documents
that have freed us.
And I think there is a pride in that
that is deeply special on the Right.
And now try to think about
what's happening on the Left.
I mean, go through the
candidates that ran.
The election and the primary
seem like a lifetime ago.
But it was like, how often
were the words liberty
or freedom or Constitution
ever said, ever said?
I keep telling people that
the one time Constitution
was said was when Kamala Harris said
she would do an executive action on guns
and Biden was like, "Hey, but
what about the Constitution?"
And she literally laughed in his face.
Is Bernie Sanders proud of
the American experiment,
the thing that he says is racist
and he basically talks about
as some sort of evil thing?
And that thing, it's dangerous,
it's actually dangerous.
It doesn't mean that America
is perfect or always right
or doesn't make bad
decisions or one president
is better than the other
or something like that.
But I think the ethos of let's
all be in on this together
and it doesn't matter if
your great-grandparents
came from Poland and my
great-grandparents came from Korea
or any other thing, it's
like, if you came here
and you work hard, that
ethos is strong on the right.
I'm not sure what the defining
thing on the left is anymore.
- When you go through your
list of facts in this chapter,
you have a hilarious
line about the pay gap
between men and women,
saying that the two things
that would survive an atomic war would be
cockroaches and this idea
that there's a pay gap
when there's not.
If there was one fact,
if there was just one piece of information
that you could stamp onto
the forehead of a left-winger
that might make him
say, "Oh, you know what?
"I gotta rethink this."
What would it be?
What was the start for
you that made you think,
"Hey, wait a minute, I've
really got this wrong"?
What's the string that
pulls the suit apart?
- You know, I think that the string for me
was that the rubber
started meeting the road.
It wasn't just that I was
waking up to these ideas
and talking to interesting thinkers.
So like when I talked to Thomas Sowell,
and we talked about economics,
here's a guy who has been
railing sort of against Leftism
and Communism and Socialism
for his whole life,
although he was a Marxist
at one time in his life,
and we talk about that, too.
So, this is another guy
who was a Lefty like us
and then who evolved into something else.
But I think what happened
was, as I started talking
about these things more
and bringing in more people
with a diverse set of
views, at the same time,
I was also building a business here
and then when I would
hear about why low taxes
and getting rid of regulation
and these things are important
and then I'd start looking at the numbers
and talking to my business
manager and my accountant
and everything else and
realizing, man, we live,
I mean, Andrew, you and I live in a state
that is obscenely high tax.
Just in the last week, because of corona,
I've been sort of half-joking about it
but it's becoming less of a joke,
thinking about maybe it is
time to get out of California.
And we were crunching some
numbers and it's like,
the amount that I would
save in a place like
Florida or Texas or Washington
or South Dakota, I mean,
the places that have
basically zero income tax,
and it's not because I want a yacht.
Although I would be perfectly
within my right to have a yacht.
It's not that I want a yacht.
We only have one car
between the two of us.
It's not that I want more stuff
but I know if my company is taxed less,
if you get regulation out
of the way, what can I do?
You know what I would do?
I would hire more people.
We just hired a new associate producer
in the middle of coronavirus
because our business
is doing well and if
you allow the government
to get out of the way and allow
you to keep what you earn,
I'm pretty sure that
everyone watching this
knows what to do with their money
better than the government does.
So, I would say the one thing is,
when you get to that moment,
because it will happen.
You know, we can talk about all this stuff
at the idea level, low
taxes, states' rights,
all of these things.
But if you live your life
sort of congruently with that,
if you live your life where
you're trying to apply
your ideals into your life,
at some point it will click.
And then suddenly there
will be a real moment
right in front of you
where you'll be like,
"Holy cow, the stuff that
I've been talking about,
"here are the papers,
here are the numbers.
"And it's in front of me and now I know
"that I'm not just saying
it, I'm living it."
- I gotta ask you one last question
because I have to know this.
The first time I was on your
show was right after, I think,
Donald Trump was elected and you asked me
about Donald Trump and
I told you that I had
this fear that there was a 5% chance
that he might be Adolph Hitler.
But in that other 95% chance,
he was much better than Hillary Clinton.
To me, he's turned out to
be a really good president.
He's done a very good job.
He reminds me of the kind of boss you have
who you sometimes don't like
but he knows how to run the business.
You know, and I think that that's
a kind of interesting thing.
Politically, you've
changed philosophically.
I've watched you change philosophically.
Have you changed politically?
Is there a point where you start to say,
"You know what?
"I'm gonna put my vote
where my philosophy is
"even if it means voting
for someone like Trump
"that I don't like that much."
- Yeah, oh man, this is the big finish
on this one, Klaven, good question.
(Klaven laughing)
So first off, let me give
you credit on something else
because I was also with you,
I was with the Daily Wire
guys the night of the election
and you said something that I
have quoted it a million times
because I think it was so on-point.
Everyone was shocked
about what was happening
and you said, "You know, what
a beautiful thing in America
"that it shows you the
flexibility of our system
"that the thing that everyone
said couldn't happen,
"that every pollster, every
expert, everyone on TV,
"every pundit, that the
thing that they just said
"couldn't happen just happened.
"What an incredible society we live in
"that that sort of thing could happen."
- Agreement is so much more fun, yeah.
- How much more fun and all of that stuff.
And you weren't even commenting
on Trump specifically.
You were just saying like,
the reality of what just
happened is so beautiful.
To answer your question,
I will tell you this,
so I am a registered
Democrat in this state
because there is so much
Democrat power in this state
and I wanted to be able
to vote in the primaries.
So I voted for Joe Biden
(coughs) excuse me,
in the primaries but it was really
just a vote against Bernie.
That was what I viewed as this
truly dangerous set of ideas.
Biden, it was sort of like,
eh, just take the vote.
You know, something like that.
But I will tell you this,
I voted against every
single measure in there
that increased taxes, every single thing.
And you have to read them and
they're completely confusing
and they say things like, you know,
"500 million more dollars for education"
and if you just look at
the headline, you're like,
"Well, of course I want more education."
And then you have to read,
read, read, read, read,
and on the bottom it says,
"And this will be intact for nine years
"and then only can be repealed by vote."
But no one ever votes
to take education away.
You just always vote to
put more money into it.
So, I would say, I would say
in effect I have no party.
I don't think having a party
is actually that important.
There's a functional
utility to having a party
in states where you can only
vote in a primary by one party.
But I don't consider myself a Democrat,
I don't consider myself a Republican.
Do I have far more in
common with Republicans?
Obviously.
And to directly answer your question,
I would say, at this
point, I've done a lot,
I think, to save the word Liberal.
I think I've really tried and
I've been one of the people
that have really tried to save it.
So that a guy like you
or a guy like Ben Shapiro
could say, "Yeah, in the true
sense I'm a classical Liberal
"and that really is modern Conservatism."
So I would say more than
anything else, in a way,
I'm a modern Conservative.
If conservatism is what
I now believe it to be,
that it isn't that you have
to buy all of these ideas
but you can have some outlier ideas,
but basically believe in the
bedrock principles of America,
then I would say I'm
a modern Conservative.
And I would just say
one other thing which is
that defending my Liberal principles
has become a Conservative position.
- Yeah, it's amazing.
I always say that, too, I
always say I'm a Conservative
because I'm a Liberal.
It's true.
"Don't Burn This Book," it's terrific
and I'm glad to see that
more people are buying it
than are burning it.
Though I know there are a lot of liberals
(laughing)
who just wanna cross out
the first word of the title.
But it's always great to talk
to you, Dave, thanks a lot.
- Klaven, thanks for doing this.
And you're back on the
show, I think, in June.
We're doing it in person regardless
of what Eric Garcetti says.
What do you say about that?
(Klaven laughing)
- I will be there with my big
black mask on, you'll see me.
- Thank you, my friend.
- Thanks a lot, it's great
talking to you, Dave.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.